la liberté de la presse n'est pas une
liberté spéciale elle est la plus haute
expression de la liberté
c'est pourquoi elle est la première
liberté supprimé par les régimes
autoritaires des propos signé du chef de
l'état lui même mais qui en disent long
sur le chemin que semble emprunter la
france blessure interpellation garde à
vue les journalistes sont de plus en
plus malmenés dans le cadre de leurs
fonctions ce qui faisait office de fait
rarissime autrefois est presque devenu
la norme aujourd'hui
et les exemples ne manquent pas le
comble de l'ironie
les dernières en date ont eu lieu lors
de manifestations de défense de la
liberté de la presse sur la place du
trocadéro samedi un policier s'en est
violemment pris à un rédacteur du site
internet média tv et lorsque quelqu'un a
tenté de lui venir en aide
il s'est retrouvé à son tour agressé
alors que je faisais mon boulot pour le
média tv à la manif stop loi sécurité
globale un policier m'a fait un
croche-pied qui m'a envoyé à terre
résultat matos cassé plusieurs centaines
d'euros de réparation je vous envoie la
facture à quelle adresse préfecture de
police déjà quatre jours avant à l'issue
de la première manifestation contre la
loi sécurité globale deux journalistes
avaient été arrêtés et placés en garde à
vue
une photographe du site taranis news et
un reporter de france 3 interpellé alors
qu'il filmait une interpellation de
manifestants
le snj apporte tout son soutien à ses
consoeurs et confrères
victime d'une grave atteinte à la
liberté de la presse
nous ne croyons pas le ministre de
l'intérieur quand il affirme que cette
loi sécurité globale garantirait aux
journalistes la possibilité de filmer et
de diffuser librement des actions de
police
et c'est bel et bien ce que gérald
darmanin affirme de nouveau
deux jours plus tard à l'assemblée
nationale et aucun policier de france
monsieur lagarde a raison aucun gendarme
de france n'est autorisée ne sera
autorisée et si c'est le cas ce sera
évidemment sanctionné et je ne doute pas
que des gens pour nous le signaler moi
même et tous les mises intérieur qui
succéderont d'empêcher quelqu'un de
filmer et s'il le fait il est contre la
loi
c'est pourtant ce qui est arrivé le
lendemain à la journaliste web de rt
france meriem laribi s'est vu menacer
d'interpellations alors qu'elle filmait
justement celle de plusieurs
manifestants
si vous souhaitez les et ce n'est pas la
seule à avoir été empêché de faire son
travail
enfin de rassemblement les forces de
police ont chargé les manifestants sans
faire de distinction avec les
journalistes une cinquantaine de
reporters de rédactions nationales et
internationales se sont retrouvés nas
est isolé du reste des manifestants
pourquoi peut-être pour les empêcher de
capturer certaines actions susceptibles
de déranger les forces de l'ordre que
les gens à licha c'est devenu riche de
toutes les rédactions sur la c on sait
qu'il part des policiers sans la
possibilité de bouger
c'est du jamais vu en france jamais vous
l'aurez compris rien ne va plus entre le
pouvoir et la presse
mais pourquoi maintenant sur la toile
certains ont leur petite idée
l'article 24 de la loi sécurité globale
montre clairement que le gouvernement
craint un embrasement social après la
crise sanitaire
il prend les devants en tentant d'en
réduire la couverture presse au strict
minimum
on ne fait pas baisser la température en
cassant le thermomètre
si la loi sécurité globale est
révélatrice d'une chose c'est que le
pouvoir a peur de l'explosion sociale à
venir suite à la crise sanitaire mais
surtout à la gigantesque crise
économique avec licenciements massifs
qu'il y aura une fois le côté sanitaire
de la crise terminée une question se
pose alors emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement ont-ils un problème avec la
liberté de la presse
après la loi sécurité globale du
ministre de l'intérieur
le garde des sceaux eric dupond moretti
a fait savoir de son côté qu'il voulait
modifier la loi de 1881 sur la liberté
de la presse au pays des lumières il
semblerait que certaines libertés sombre
peu à peu dans les ténèbres